[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain an american romantic fantasy
film called the age of adeline
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the protagonist of the movie is a 29
year old woman named adeline bowman in
the beginning she walks into an
apartment and buys a fake id under a
different name she returns back home to
feed her dog then goes to work it is a
normal day in san francisco for adeline
until her co-worker hands her archives
containing reels of historical events
adeline excitedly agrees to sort through
them and brings the box home she sets up
a projector and watches videos of the
historic times in fascination it is
narrated that adeline was actually born
on january 1st 1908 in 1929 she married
a young man named clarence james and
only three years later she gave birth to
a baby girl fleming adeline was the
happiest she could ever be but her life
turned upside down when her husband died
in a tragic accident during the
construction of the golden gate bridge
in 1937. ten months after her husband's
death adeline was driving to her parents
cottage that night snow fell in the
otherwise dry sonoma county california
adeline had poor visibility on the road
because of the snowfall which caused her
to crash into a ravine tragically she
died freezing in the water but something
magical happened next she was struck by
lightning and brought back to life and
from that moment onwards adeline hasn't
aged a second as she grew older she
realized she had this unique condition
but thought it was because of a good
diet exercise and simple luck this is
what magazines want us to believe but
it's not usually true
but as time passed her appearance at her
age became almost abnormal her daughter
fleming grew older and the two started
looking like sisters as adeline didn't
age
one day she is pulled over by a
policeman for a minor traffic
inconvenience but the man doesn't
believe she is 45 years old this makes
adeline realize she cannot live with her
condition hence she moves to san
francisco a city where everyone is fake
from her suburban neighborhood to study
medicine and research her condition
however even after a year of research
she acquires little to no information
about her condition she is eventually
forced to accept the fact that there is
no scientific explanation for why she
doesn't age
one night while returning home she is
approached by fbi agents who suspect her
of being a spy because of lack of record
of residence they pull over their car by
a plane and taking the opportunity
adeline flees from the place
starting then she has always been on the
run moving from state to state and
changing her name every few years it is
currently 2014 and adeline is 106 years
old but neither her appearance nor her
health has changed since she was 29. her
daughter fleming has aged gradually and
looks old enough to be adeline's mother
currently she is living as jennifer
larson and is about to move in seven
weeks under a different name on her
107th birthday adeline's blind friend
regan invites her to a new year's eve
party adeline dresses up beautifully and
arrives at a lavish mansion there she
sees decades-old pictures of herself and
reminisces about her friends adeline
meets regan who jokes about only younger
men liking her not knowing that she
doesn't age while they talk adeline
locks eyes with a handsome young man
across the room named ellis jones they
exchange a few glances but do not talk
throughout the night when the clock hits
midnight adeline is about to leave when
ellis joins her in the elevator they
introduce themselves and get to know
more about each other adeline introduces
herself as jennifer trying to stay as
far away from him as possible it is
clear that ellis is more interested in
her than she is in him he awkwardly
escorts her out and asks her how they
can meet again but adeline leaves after
wishing him a happy new year the
following day she goes to meet fleming
for lunch the mother and daughter hug
and have a happy conversation fleming
tells adeline about her plan to move
into a retirement home somewhere far
away which adeline is not happy about
because she wants to stay closer to her
daughter adeline is nostalgic and wants
to see her daughter in diapers again the
next day adeline is surprised to see
ellis walk into her work ellis has
become a stalker in a single day he has
somehow found out where she works and
has brought her books as gifts this time
he bravely asks her out on a date and
seeing the man try so hard adeline
agrees besides he probably knows where
she lives she asks him to take her to a
place she has never been before in san
francisco ellis accepts the challenge
and takes her to the recently found
historic tunnel an impressed adeline
asks him many questions but when it's
her turn to talk about herself she only
mentions that she has a dog before
leaving adeline tells him about her
plans to move to a different state soon
hearing this ellis asks her out on a
second date and makes her accept it
after telling an awful joke in the
following scene adeline goes to ellis's
apartment for their date ellis surprises
her again with his innovative dish the
two have a wonderful conversation while
drinking wine and listening to jazz
music alice tells her about his father
who is an astronomer and is famous for
discovering an unusual comet he also
reveals that the new year's party wasn't
when he first saw adeline ellis is
somehow still getting creepier in fact
he had first seen her a while ago
sitting near the library in a blue dress
and instantly felt drawn to her the two
look into each other's eyes and move
closer to kiss but adeline pulls away
refusing to act on her feelings she is
afraid to be close to anyone since she
is always moving and changing her
identities ellis hides his
disappointment and asks her more about
herself his words overwhelm adeline and
the two finally kiss the following
morning they wake up on ellis bed as
adeline goes to work that day she passes
a park and remembers the time a man was
waiting for her on the same park bench
it was her lover from a long time ago
who wanted to marry her but adeline had
to leave him because of her condition
later adeline walks home to her dog
lying limp on the floor she rushes him
to the vet and finds out that his
kidneys have failed so it would be best
to put him down later adeline returns
home distressed and looks at an album
with the pictures of dogs she has had
over the years this might be the worst
thing about immortality at night she is
walking to her apartment when ellis
approaches her with a bouquet of flowers
he had left her several voicemails which
she didn't answer so he went out of his
way to figure out her address from her
work dear god ellis pump the brakes
adeline informs him about her dog's
death and tells him he shouldn't have
invaded her privacy she leaves abruptly
after asking him to stay away the
following day she meets fleming again
and tells her about ellis fleming
advises her mother to let go and live
her life for once go ahead mom stalkers
are cool adeline feels sorry for being
rude to alice the other day and goes to
his work to apologize the two then go
out for a date at night this time
adeline takes him to a drive-in movie
theater from the 60s she passionately
explains the history of the theater to
an impressed ellis they get in one of
the cars and watch the stars drawn on
the ceiling ellis then invites her for
another date to his parents house for
their 40th anniversary adeline agrees on
the condition that she will be driving
the next day they drive to ellis's
parents home and pick up ellis sister
kiki on the way when the three finally
reach there they are welcomed by alice's
parents william and kathy as soon as
william sees adeline he says her name
adeline is in shock but corrects him
saying that her name is jennifer the two
share awkward eye contact after which
adeline claims that william must have
known her mother william is visibly
shaken seeing how much jennifer looks
like his old friend adeline hence he is
in utmost shock when jennifer tells him
adeline passed away a few years ago
after everyone goes to sleep william
pours himself a glass of wine and
reminisces about the time he first met
adeline he was only 26 years old and she
was 29 when he helped her fix her car
the two instantly got along and even
though adeline went by the name della at
the time she told william her real name
the two quickly fell in love and
traveled to america together it is then
revealed that william was the man who
was about to propose to adeline at the
park but adeline got to know about it
and stood him up she actually loved him
but couldn't risk her secret being out
back in the present adeline cannot fall
asleep at night over breakfast william
again brings up adeline and talks about
how nice of a person she was his face
lights up when he talks about her and as
he praises her his wife kathy gets up
and walks away william goes behind her
to ask her what is wrong and finds out
that she feels like a second option to
him after adeline he reassures her that
he loves her and the two kiss the day
passes and at night the family gathers
for a game they have a tradition of
playing a tabletop trivia game that
william has a 47-game winning streak on
as the family talks kiki says that the
comet william discovered is called della
the family believes that the name is set
after william's aunt but adeline
realizes he named it after her she holds
her tears and continues playing the game
with the family she eventually beats
william's record and wins the game
surprising everyone if he's surprised
now wait until he finds out what his
ex-girlfriend is doing with his son
a while later adeline goes out for a
walk and is startled to see william who
is stargazing the two have a nice chat
and william tells her he was about to
propose to her mother before leaving
adeline also confesses that her mother
loved him no matter what in the
following scene madeline is back in bed
with ellis he eventually confesses he
has fallen in love with her and cannot
imagine his life without her in it she
smiles but doesn't say i love you back
the next morning adeline goes for a walk
and runs into william again he sees a
ladybug on her head and helps her remove
it while he is at it william notices a
scar on adeline's wrist that is
identical to the one his girlfriend
adeline had he remembers it clearly
because he was the one that stitched the
wound for her and even has a picture of
them together where adeline's hand is
bandaged he finally confronts her and
asks her for the truth adeline comes
clean she tells him she doesn't know how
it started but she doesn't age she also
admits that her condition was the reason
she left him william asks her if she
will leave his son as well adeline gets
overwhelmed at the question and runs
back to the house in a hurry she quickly
packs her bags and leaves a note for
ellis who is still in the shower as
always adeline has decided to run away
so she wouldn't hurt anyone then she
steals his car she drives away as
william tries to stop her when ellis
comes out of the shower he is
heartbroken to see the note he gets
dressed and asks william what he said to
adeline william just says that she is
not ready for the change he asks his son
if he actually loves adeline ellis says
he does because nothing in life makes
sense without her even though he hasn't
known her for long
hearing this william hands his car key
to ellis urging him to go look for
adeline ellis flexes his stalker skills
and calls adeline numerous times on his
way but she ignores all the calls she
pulls over her car coincidentally near
the same place her accident took place
decades ago adeline reminisces about the
times she has run away from life and
realizes she loves alice too much to
stay without him she then calls fleming
and tells her she is going to settle in
life however after the call adeline gets
hit by a speeding car her body lies limp
by the side of the road and for the
first time in 78 years it snows in
sonoma county as the temperature drops
adeline freezes and her heartbeat
eventually stops
just then ellis arrives there and
performs cpr to try to bring her back a
while later the paramedics arrive at the
scene and place two defibrillator
paddles on adeline's chest they
administer 750 volts of electricity
similar to the one she had gotten when
the lightning struck her decades ago
because of it she finally takes a breath
and is brought back to life in the
following scene adeline is in the
hospital with ellis he apologizes for
saying i love you too fast but adeline
kisses him claiming that she loves him
too she then opens up about her
condition to him and reveals that she is
actually 107 years old upon hearing this
ellis dumps her immediately just kidding
strangely ellis is calm even after
hearing the truth it is now a year later
ellis and adeline are a happy couple
living together adeline even has a new
puppy that fleming looks after most of
the time one night the couple plans to
go out to a new year's party while
getting ready adeline notices a single
gray hair on her head the movie ends as
it is revealed that she has started to
age again
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching